[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXIS MUTSCHLER: We're
here because the roof
and the cupola on Nassau
Hall need to be restored.
It's been 60 years since
the roof or the cupola
have been touched.
The roof was last replaced
in the late 1950s.
As a result, in the
past decade or so,
we've done a lot
of roof repairs,
including chasing leaks.
Age and weather has taken a
very large toll on the cupola.
The copper seams have started
separating through the years.
And as a result, water
has been getting in
through the copper seams.
And it has not only
rusted the iron structure,
but it's also gotten
behind the stucco
and allowed it to
crack and separate
from the main brick structure.
It is very important
to the university
as well as to the
municipality to make sure
that the cupola is restored
in its proper fashion
and is historically accurate.
The project team
spent a great deal
of time working with the
Princeton University Library
as well as other
sources to find out
what the original
cupola looked like when
it was last reconstructed
in the 1920s.
We found some really neat things
while we started construction.
The people who cast
all the copper --
we could still
see their markings
for how they were putting
the pieces together,
and even some math
notes that they did.
It's amazing
because none of this
can be seen from the ground.
But up close, it
really is pretty cool
seeing that little
bit of history.
If we do our job
right, the cupola
will look almost exactly
the same, only better.
The biggest difference
will be that it
will take about 20 years
for the bright copper
to turn the beautiful
patina green that we've
grown so accustomed to.
Working on this building
is truly an honor.
The fact that this building
has played such a vital role
in our history as a nation --
just thinking of all
the men and women
who've gone through this
building, and the role they
played --
is truly humbling.
And it's an honor to be able to
be a part of its past, present,
and future.